My name is Devin.
I'm a solutions
engineer at Posit,
and I'm really thrilled
to be up here today
to talk about Quarto
because in many ways,
the vision of Quarto that
reproducible research is
a core part of high quality
scientific communications
was a key driver and
actually nudging me
along my career
journey that ultimately
has brought me to Posit.
Almost 10 years ago
as a graduate student,
R Markdown
blew me away when
all of a sudden,
I could shortcut
an enormous amount of
the tedious interactions
from working in our
scripts and actually taking
the outputs of those, getting
it them into Word or PDF
documents to distribute.
Now as many graduate
students are inclined to do.
I also dabbled in
figuring out how I could
use the tools I was learning.
In particular are
in fun new ways.
So about that time, a new
tool emerged called Git book.
And it was really
fascinating to me
because the idea was to take
a bunch of Markdown documents,
jam them through this
processor and out popped
a website that had
navigation and styling
and it kind of
looked like a book.
And so I said, hmm, that
seems kind of interesting.
I wonder if I can take
R Markdown documents,
get them to Markdown to
put them through Git book.
And so I put together
some really, really scary
looking code.
But thankfully, the
RStudio team was also
keeping an eye on such ideas.
And bookdown,
entered the scene.
This ability to build on a
unit of an R Markdown document
into more complex content felt
like a taste of opportunities
to come.
And so similarly, when
I started playing around
with what it was going to
be like to build a blog,
I found Hugo, a
static site generator
that you could also make most
of your content with Markdown.
And so by using that content
and Markdown plus a little bit
of metadata and
configuration, you
could generate a
professional looking site.
Again the RStudio team
responded with blogdown.
And it was so exciting to
me because there's actually
official tools to support
these janky workflows that I
was trying to come up with.
That integration between
Hugo and Markdown
was able to help
bring content to life.
But as fascinating
as these experiments
were, as fascinating as
learning those tools were,
it was undeniable that there
were some significant points
of friction and frustration
in figuring it out, especially
around the tooling boundaries.
It was never fun to see a Hugo
theme that just kind of didn't
work for how you
wanted to lay it out
or something that
worked in bookdown
that you couldn't
put into blogdown.
And so, as powerful
as these tools were,
it was clear that the separation
of the communities that we're
trying to meld together
left some gaps to make
this approachable to everyone.
But here we are today.
And, as Mine and
Julie have explained,
and hopefully as everyone
is getting so excited about,
Quarto builds on the
learnings of the past decade.
It unifies teams across
language, boundaries
and procedural differences.
And in the same
vein, Quarto can also
unify the way you consider
building those books, blogs,
websites, or all sorts
of other complex content.
So you can focus
on enabling users
to discover, consume
and navigate in the ways
that you'd like to help them.
And by doing so in a
single unified tool chain,
it really does give you
an unparalleled ability
to control the
processing and ultimately
the production of the content
that you're working on.
Now, one thing that some
of you may be thinking,
is this seems like a lot.
One tool that can do so much.
How may I even start
learning all of the things
that it can do?
So today I'm going
to do something
that hopefully the presentation
gods will be with me
and I'm going to show
you just how easy it
is to get going with Quarto
and do some pretty cool stuff
and hopefully also
demonstrate about some
of the thoughtfulness
that the Quarto
team has put into its design.
So they switch over.
So I can actually
see what I'm typing.
Oh, man.
Where's my mouse?
In I'm hoping that's
going to give it back.
All right.
I want to mirror.
And we're in business.
All right.
So let's drop into RStudio.
Now, one of the things that
you can always do in RStudio
is if you want to go play around
with a somewhat recent version
of our Quarto, you can go
in, create a new directory,
and Quarto is front and center.
But the Quarto team
has wanted to make sure
that Quarto is available, even
if you're not in using rstudio,
if you're using VS Code
or any other editor
and so many to all the things
that you can do in the IDE,
you can also do on
the command line.
In this case, we want to
get going with a website.
So in this case, I
can from the terminal
say quarto create project.
Type equals website.
And what this is going to do is
start me off with a scaffold.
It has a couple of
these qmd files
that you've been hearing about.
And it has this quarto HTML.
This is the magic, the
ability to say I have the area
that I'm going to
write my content,
and I have a hub where
I can control how I want
that content to be rendered.
So if I want to
take this content,
maybe add a little bit
more structure to it.
So here is a header
and maybe we'll.
Add a list, some Markdown.
Some more interesting stuff.
And I can render it.
And what's going to
pop up is my site.
Now let's look at this
site really briefly.
I have a title.
I have a home and an about page.
You can see my header that I
can actually link to in case,
I want to get someone
directly there.
If it's a longer page and I
even have a table of contents,
if I have more elements.
So I can see how I would
navigate through that page.
Now you could go build
this today in blogdown.
No problem.
But where things start to
get exciting to me in quarto
is just how flexible
you can be when you say,
what if I want to
move things around?
So in this case, you can
see how this is laid out.
I have my website, I have a
title that I could change.
I also have a bar, so that
top strip is a navbar.
But if I instead said, I
want to move my content
so it's on the left
right, which is actually
one of the big things that would
differentiate for like a book.
It's quite simple.
I could just say
this is a sidebar.
And I want to take
some contents.
And if I go back here and
I want to regenerate it.
My site now has no bar,
and instead my contents
are on the side.
You don't have to
decide up front.
Is this a book?
Is this a blog?
Because Quarto is
giving you the ability
to put things in
the way you want
and you can combine
the ideas that
make books great, blogs great
or any other different type
of layout.
And much of that is
accessible directly
with a couple lines of code
in this configuration file.
And so I'm going to bring back
the navbar for a little bit.
And let's talk about
blogs, because I
think that's one entry
point for a lot of people
where you can start to dabble
with things that you're
learning.
You know, maybe it's
stuff at the conferences,
maybe it's some of your
own personal learnings
that you want to
put up to the world.
And so what I want to do
is I want to add some more
organization to this content.
And so I'm going to
make a post directory.
And in that post
directory, I'm going
to make a Quarto document.
My first post.
Now, one of the
things that you're
going to see coming up right
here is the visual editor.
Now, this isn't directly
relevant to or directly enabled
only by Quarto, but
this is something
that to me is so exciting
about the blend of what Quarto
offers, plus what the RStudio
IDE can also bring to the table.
So for some people, the
ability to write Markdown
is fine for text.
But as soon as you start
doing more complex things
like dealing with images,
it becomes tedious.
Remember, oh, what is that?
Is exclamation point bracket
or is it parentheses?
I can't keep track.
How do I get stuff in?
And suddenly going back to
a Google Doc or something
feels a lot more
approachable with Quarto
and the visual editor.
You get that.
What you see is what you get.
Interface if you want that
now, I can always switch back
to the source if I'm
comfortable writing that,
but the visual editor has
some pretty nice goodies
hidden inside of it.
For example, if I wanted
to clear all of this out.
So let's just take
this away real quick.
To do and say I'm
here at NETCONF.
Our RStudio has just rebranded.
And you know what?
I think it would be great
to also add a screenshot,
so I'm going to save
this into my posts.
I'm going to say my
conference experience.
And let's go over to the Corps
or the new posit website.
And for fun and games,
I'm going to whoops,
that went pretty fast.
I'm going to grab a little
screenshot maybe boom,
I grabbed that screenshot.
I'm going to copy
it to my clipboard.
Now before the visual editor.
I'd have to save this out.
I'd have to put
it in a directory,
I'd have to move that around.
I much prefer just pasting it.
And the visual editor
has now taken that
and stuck it in an
image directory for me.
These quality of
life improvements
are all throughout
the Quarto ecosystem.
To showcase another
one real quick.
If I look here and I wonder,
you know, oh, what was it?
Was it side bar?
Was it side something I can
start typing and with some tab
completion, it's going to
tell me what my options are.
Now notice this isn't a long
list of every possible option.
It's just the options relevant
for that level of indentation.
In this case, I could
say true or false,
or if I indent again
and then ask and say,
tell me what things I
could do with the sidebar.
You see this come up right
here and I can say, Oh yeah,
I could put some contents in.
The things that could
frustrate you and make you
feel like you needed
to pull your hair out.
The IDE and Quarto and
the tooling built around
it is trying to help you
not have to deal with that
and be able to focus
on your content.
And so I have this first kind
of conference experience,
a page here.
And what I'm going
to do is I'm also
going to go kind of steal
just for the sake of time,
another kind of post starter
that I grabbed right off
of the website.
So we can also stick
this in the Posit's page.
All right.
So what we have here
is I've added another,
more complex Quarto document
that has a bunch more
stuff going on to it.
And the majority of the intent
of this doesn't matter so much.
This is on the court's website,
so you can explore about it.
But the point is, is
I'm starting to build up
multiple blog posts.
And so how are you going to
display those for your user?
If we think about what
a blog might have,
you might have something
that's sorted by date.
It shows an author,
maybe an image preview.
It gives that stuff to you so
you can see what's going on.
And so instead of making
it look like it's magical
and I can remember how to do
this off the top of my head,
this is a great opportunity to
go over to the courthouse site
to say if this was the first
time I was considering trying
to build a blog and I
wanted to go look at it,
I can go and look
through the search.
And Quarto is going to give you
a whole bunch of information
on that site about what
to do for blogging.
And so in this case, I can
scroll down a little bit
and they say, hey, if you
are dealing with a blog,
you can grab this.
And what we can see here is the
idea of some configuration that
allows us to say,
you're going to want
to display some listings,
you have some contents.
That's going to be a
bunch of different posts,
assumed documents or
otherwise, and you're probably
going to want to do
something with this.
So let's just steal this
right from the site.
I'm going to make
a new document.
And we're just going to come in.
We're going to clear
it all out and I'm just
going to paste this in.
So call this the blog.
Save it.
And in the top, we'll
call this the blog.
Should I get in the right spot?
All right, so now I have
this blog Shad file,
and I just have to say
where I want it to be.
In this case, I'd
be completely fine
with it being right next to
that home and that about.
So I'll say.
Text is blog.
And href is
blog.qmd.
Now notice the contents are the
contents is this post folder.
If I had a different
folder name,
I'd give it a different thing.
So now let's go check at
what this whole site is
going to look like.
So everything got rendered.
I can go to my about
page, I can go to my blog,
and you can see here that I have
these pages that I can click in
and I already have
a pretty great
looking thing right
out of the box
that shows all sorts of
information about it.
You can see the author,
the publication date
and a whole bunch of images.
Now content is great looking
at it on your laptop,
but realistically
the true excitement
is when you can actually
get this out to the world.
And so the quarto team has
also wanted to make sure
they could make this as easy
as possible for everyone.
And so I'm going
to come in here.
I did notice as I was
copying things around,
I blew away that
old positive image.
So let me go clean that kind
of broken link up real quick.
I saw the air flash around.
So if I go into my images, post
that copy paste of the starter
killed it off.
So I want to save
that real quick.
So here I am, I want to
get this to the world.
So let's go back to the
quarto command line.
In this case, I can say.
quarto publish and there are a
number of different end points
if you use our
RStudio Connect that
is, of course, one of them.
There's Netlify if
you've ever heard that.
But one other thing that, I'm so
excited to show is QuartoPub.
And in this case, I can
say I would absolutely
like to publish.
I have a site that by default
is going to be the folder name,
but I can give it
any name I want.
And up it goes.
It's uploading all of
the elements to the site.
It's deploying it.
And in just a moment,
we now have a live site
available to the world.
Now I know I'm running a
little bit short on time.
And I have a couple more
things that I want to show.
And to me, the thing,
if I look at this blog
and I look at this
fun photography
filled site with a
bunch of complex layout
that is great to kind
of inspect and analyze.
This is all well and
good, but wouldn't it
be nice if we could add
some more interactivity?
And so one of the
things that kind of
made me a little nervous
when looking at Quarto,
one toolchain to
rule them all is
what if you want to do something
that's not in the tool chain?
And so what the
quartet team has done
is they've built up this
concept of quarto extensions.
We have a couple extensions
already out there.
And so in this case,
one of the extensions
is called the
lightbox extension.
And so this allows you to
add some styling to images.
And so you can see right here
there's some great installation
instructions.
So let's just see what
happens if we run this.
I'm going to say absolutely.
I do trust the authors.
My extend.
I have now installed an
extension right from GitHub
into my site.
And then I can go
and I can go to this.
Pictures page and
in the configuration
we can see you need to add
this extra little bit of syntax
on filters and lightbox.
So let's take a look at
what this looks like now.
And so if I go to this
fun photography now,
I have what to me
comes out as a much
more professional
photography looking website.
I can pop things out.
You can scroll across
them with the magic
of pulling in an
extension and extensions
can do this in so much more.
If you want to think about
themes for your company,
layouts for documents
or all sorts
of other advanced
functionality, there's
a whole bunch of delight
that these extensions
are bringing to the table.
You might have heard of vetiver.
One of the cool things about
vetiver is it is multilingual,
but that meant bringing
multilingual code snippets
throughout the entire site.
But if you want to go and
you're interested in python,
I don't want to have
to click through Python
across every single
tab on the site.
One Quarto extension made.
Now all of my tabs are
synced across the language
that I pick every single
time I come back to this.
So the Quarto
extension ecosystem
is going to allow the community
and the Quarto developers
to really take Quarto and expand
to do so much more beyond what
it can even do out of the box.
So there's so, so much
that we haven't had time
to talk to about
today with Quarto.
So I want to close
with one suggestion.
There's a gallery in Quarto.
That covers a whole bunch of
stuff that you can do with it.
Go there for some inspiration.
You know, of course, things
like the website is there,
but there are people
that are generating
some really awesome hybrid
sites that can do so much.
One of the my favorites
that I've seen
is like this mlr3 book.
This is what a book looks like
with Quarto that you can make.
And there are so many little
good bits like the fact
that you can actually
embed the code that
generated the site
right there to pop out,
if you like, things like
light themes or dark themes
or otherwise.
There is so much
to discover there.
So take a look, read around
and most importantly, go out
and play with Quarto.
You can get going.
So fast and you can have so
much fun while you're at it.
And while you're
along that, please
don't hesitate to reach
out to the Porto team.
And so with that, I'll just
kind of leave this up there,
but I really hope you
all go out and build.
Thank you.